- Good morning everyone.
Thank you for joining us
this morning. I'm Catherine,
I'm a director in the UK PWC firm
working in the health team.
I'm joined today with my colleague Andy,
who works in our local public
sector team in the UK firm
and Nicola, our client who works
for the National Health
Service in the UK at a hospital
just outside of London.
We want to come and talk
to you today about how
amazing AWS products have
been transforming the public
sector and the work that
we are doing in the UK.
I think for those of you who
don't really know much about
the UK, the National Health Service
is actually the biggest
employer in Europe.
And despite the fact
that you've got millions
of people working for the
NHS, the waiting list for
kind of access to the healthcare is
10% of the population on a waiting list.
They just don't have
enough capacity to see all
of the people, all of the
customers who want to,
to get access to health.
And the fact that it's the
most trusted institution in the
UK, even the the kind of
waiting times are basically
what dominate the sort
of citizen perception,
giving it a really bad reputation.
And even though the NHS
app is actually one of
the most used healthcare
apps in the world,
the technology landscape in
the NHS in the UK is pretty
complex, really outdated,
and you know, very limited use
of digital AI and Cloud.
This actually gives us a
huge opportunity though
to do some really, really exciting stuff
to improve that citizen experience.
So Andy, we obviously learned
a huge amount from the work
that you were doing in local councils.
Do you want to kind of reflect
on the sort of learnings
that you've got from that work?
- Yeah, sure. So I think as
you've just seen from the video,
we started off working with
Amazon Connect in local council,
so local government in the UK,
and I think we found three
things that we can do
really quickly.
- I don't think your mic is working
- Hopefully you can hear me?
Otherwise I'm gonna
have to talk like this,
which would be a little bit difficult.
Hopefully someone can turn
me up. Lemme just pull that.
So the first thing was is that
you can do things really fast.
So we can deploy Amazon
Connect in 10 to 15 days
for a full contact center migration.
We can release 30% of a
typical contact center's
capacity in a matter of 10 weeks.
And with the right governance
and decision making,
that means you can achieve
results really fast.
One of the things we wanted
to do is take that learning
and transfer it into the health service.
Second thing is there's
a lot of components.
So once you create it once
you've got a reusable asset
that builds in quality,
that builds in pace,
that builds in a lot of things
that mean that we don't have
to worry so much about
the specific requirements
of a given industry.
We can move from one to
the next very, very fast.
And last thing is, councils really do need
to modernize fast.
They have, they're running out money,
they have increasing citizen expectations.
The two components to
be put together meant
that people were willing to say,
"Alright, I'm gonna go and try that."
I know I can fail fast,
I know I'm not committed.
If it doesn't work, let's get
involved and let's get it done quickly.
- Amazing. And so I think
having heard that story
and the success that we had
in local government, Nicola,
what was it that really interested you
and how we could apply it into the NHS?
- Yeah, so I think as you said,
patients are waiting easily a year
for a routine appointment.
So when I say we have a long
wait, we have a long wait.
On top of that, Medway, where I work,
is an incredibly deprived area.
We have really poor engagement
with healthcare, huge numbers
of drug abuse, alcohol
abuse, social deprivation.
And it makes it harder for
our patients to be able
to access our healthcare.
If I tell you that our average reading age
of our demographic is six,
so incredibly challenged,
Um, one of the things that we
really wanted to understand is
how we can improve how we
communicate with our patients
and how our patients are
able to communicate with us.
Not only that, we, by starting work
with PWC at the very
beginning, we average at
around 120,000 calls into
our contact center a year.
50% of those were going unanswered.
And that's not because our staff was
sat there doing nothing.
It was the sheer volume of numbers.
That converts there into
patients that either want
to change their appointment,
can't attend their appointment,
and therefore we don't know about that,
we have wasted appointments,
therefore you're waiting
even longer than a year
because we are not utilizing
our opportunity within our
clinic templates.
So we really wanted to
understand how we could work
with a company like AWS to try
and put something in that
really supported our patients.
But not only that, it supported our staff.
Because we weren't answering the calls,
we were getting a lot
of very angry patients,
um, and that was coming down
onto our staff that are some
of our lower paid staff,
and we're coming in every day to a barrage
of abuse from patients
A, because they've waited for
a year for their appointment
and B, they've tried to call 12 times
and no one's answering the call.
So I think we were looking at, it wasn't
around could we have, let's
get AI and what can it fix?
It was around where are our problems
and how can AI potentially
support some of the issues
that we've got as an organization?
- Yeah, amazing. And you know, it's,
it's fairly easy if you
look across, you know,
what do citizens want, what
are they calling up for?
Majority of that, 80% of
that is like really easily,
you know, self-served,
you know, stuff like,
I think majority of them was
"Where do I park my car?"
as a kind of really low bar
for citizen experience.
So Andy, I think you mentioned
earlier about the fact
that you know, it's quite
financially challenged
and I think everything is around outcomes
and how you improve that.
What was it you in particular
found around kind of,
improving customer experience
whilst also reducing cost?
- Yeah, so I think there's
probably four things to call out.
So the first is that using Lex and Lambda
we're able to automate
a large volume of that
simple transactional contact.
That means that calls never go unanswered.
It means that there's an
effective answer each time
and it means that that's capacity
that's not spent on
the phone when it could
be doing something more valuable.
And certainly what we saw in Birmingham,
the example you probably
saw on the video there was
that 55% of inbound
calls could be automated
and have been automated.
So that's 55% of total
volumes of calls attempted,
not just those that an agent could get to.
The second is that we can drive really
high level of quality.
So 80% of all calls in
Birmingham, again were
answered effectively to
the customer satisfaction,
and with that journey being fulfilled.
So we've now got high level
of automation delivered
at high level of quality.
The other is it's available 24/7
'cause the robot doesn't sleep.
And that gives us a
huge advantage for some
of those marginalized communities
who perhaps can't contact in
the hours that traditionally
public sector organizations would offer.
But the third thing, and I think the thing
that makes it really powerful
is that by connecting again
with Lambda into back office systems,
we could actually fulfill
the end-to-end journey.
So you wanna raise the
case? Yeah, we can do that.
You want to start in process
and eligibility assessment?
Yeah, we can do that. And
it means that it wasn't
as if we were providing an automation
to just hold someone in stasis.
We were actually delivering
what they needed,
when they needed it, accurately,
first time, right every time.
- Yeah. Fantastic. And I think Nicola,
it really resonates when you
say this isn't just about
AI as a buzzword, where
can we throw it at?
It's actually really
understanding what problems
that you're trying to solve.
So obviously we implemented
Connect, Bedrock,
Lex, Lambda.
What in particular was it
that you were trying to solve
and what was the impact
that this technology had?
- I think Andy's referenced
it beautifully with
how transferable this
kind of automation is.
So as I said, we wanted
to start it with a basic
kind of rollout within the organization.
I'll apologize now if any of
you are clinicians in the room.
They are the hardest group
of people to work with
in trying to put any kind of change in.
So we didn't want to
come full bang with it,
let's automate radiology
reporting, let's do,
let's take it away from that
and actually understand what
we can do so it is scalable
and we can then build up
to doing those things.
So I think for us with the,
with our contact center,
we wanted to understand
the number of patients
that were now able to get through.
So we have something called A DNA,
so it's a "did not attend".
We monitor that on a
percentage on a weekly basis.
We can understand how many of our patients
didn't come for their appointment,
why did they not come?
That has dropped by 4%
since we started this,
which doesn't sound huge,
but it's a massive amount
of patients for us within six weeks.
It took six weeks to deploy
this within our area,
once we kind of had the go ahead
and got through all the
information governance element
of all of it, 80% of our
calls are now automated,
which means, that's, you
know, out of 110,000,
that's 80, 90,000 a year that are not
having to have a person answer that.
We've always given the
patients the ability
to have a human being there.
We have a lot of elderly patients,
a lot of patients that
have neurodiversity,
have learning difficulties.
There's still that human person
if they want to talk to them.
But we've saved I think patient minutes.
We are saving tens of thousands a month
in the fact that
those calls are answered
straight away now.
As you referenced with the
council, it's open 24/7,
it's not just open nine to five
while people are working normally,
it does it in multiple languages.
We have a huge immigrant population
that are non-English speaking
as their first language.
So again, the accessibility
that it's given our patients
has gone through the roof.
The patient feedback we are receiving now,
it's gone from that
cohort of patients that,
like I said, were giving our staff abuse.
It's flipped completely to
now an incredibly happy group
of patients that are like,
"Why did we not do this
years and years ago?"
So I think the impact is
massively tangible for us.
- Yeah, no, it's really exciting
and it's such a compelling
story really for something
that's pretty simple.
- It is, yeah.
- So I mean obviously not everything is
a really easy ride.
Andy, what were the kind of challenges
that you in particular faced
and I guess more importantly,
what are the specifics
that are really important
to get right when you
are deploying this?
- So I think one of the
things we take for granted is
that the labels we give
to things mean anything
to our customers and our citizens.
Actually the title of something
that's used internally
may have no meaning whatsoever to
your average person on the
street who just wants a thing.
So the first thing you got
get your head around is
how do we accurately
understand their intent?
So it's not about what are
the words they're using,
it's what is the thing
they're trying to do
and how are we using the
technology to help us understand
that and resolve it down to
a thing we can then act on?
And there was an interesting
example in Medway
where there's obviously some
clinical language that's used,
which is beyond the sort
of, the normal parameters
that something like Lex
would be able to accommodate.
So then there's a Bedrock
lookup that can go
and find the really
complex medical language,
resolve that down so it's accurate,
'cause that's one thing
you don't wanna get wrong.
I think the second thing is,
is that you've probably heard
that phrase about "Don't let
perfect be the enemy of good."
And coming back to clinicians
being harsh judges,
you'll never get something that's perfect
and you'll never get
something that's 100% right.
But the half of the job here
is to get your MVP at 80%,
put that into production
and use the feedback
that you get to make it
as close to perfect as you can.
But of course what that relies on is that
you've got the ability
to change things quickly.
So again, this is where
the tool set really
comes into its own 'cause
you can make those changes
as you go, as part of the
continuous improvement method
of the actual service
that you're engaging with.
And it's that fusion of, if
you like, the business process
and the technology configuration,
that means you can make
progress very, very quickly.
- Yeah, great. And I think the work
that was done at Medway is so replicable
that we're now putting
it into multiple other
NHS organizations.
So I think the learnings for that of like,
what you can get done in six weeks,
and now Nicola, as a
phenomenally rapid period of time
to, to get this up and running,
where did you kind of take it next and
what's the kind of future for you?
- So I'm gonna start by saying the fact
that I am stood at this
conference talking to you guys,
I am the least "techie" person
you are ever going to meet.
The fact I know what Agentic AI now is,
I have sat there listening to
the geniuses at AWS talking,
Googling stuff as they're talking to me.
So, this is so exciting
for me and for my trust,
We are not reputationally known
as being a transformational organization.
The fact that we have big
London teaching hospitals
coming to us and asking
us how we've done this,
how we've done this so quickly,
and I think a lot of that has
been around the engagement,
how we've engaged with our staff.
So if you look at our contact
center, we didn't go in
because the minute you talk
about AI, people think,
"Well that's it, my job's
gone, I'm losing my job,
they're replacing me with a computer."
So we've been really
careful about how we've gone
to those teams and involved
them right from the beginning.
They've been part of the design.
And I think the reason that we did that,
because we wanted them to
support what we are doing.
Because if they weren't gonna do that,
this was never gonna work.
And I think that's huge.
I think next for us,
oh God, where do we go?
It's the sky's the limit,
the scalability of this now
for us as an organization,
we've done a number, whilst
we've been deploying,
we've been doing scoping work
to understand, what can we do?
So if I give you an example,
within Medway we have five prisons.
So just for us, our prison organi,
our prison population is huge.
They're again, a massively
challenged demographic
of patients to reach out to
and get that engagement with.
So we are now looking at
how we get a regional hub
within Kent and Medway to
support with all of that for
other hospital trusts
within our own localities.
We're rolling out the
work we've already done
to other areas.
So we have, Canter is in
the next one we're going to,
that's built and ready to
be deployed as we speak.
But we're also looking, the
NHS is under a massive amount
of financial pressure, huge amount.
We have huge efficiencies.
My organization has a 50
million pound saving target
this year, which I know in AWS
terms that's pocket change,
but for an NHS hospital trust,
it's a huge amount of money.
And we have to hold, you
know, look at that awful,
how do we, how do we take people out?
Which is not a nice thing to do,
but we are now looking at
what we can roll out in some
of our back office functions.
So looking at HR, finance, again, those,
it's the same methodology,
but do you need someone to tell you
how much annual leave you've got left
or when your payslip should be coming out?
So again, it's looking at
where we can scale this to.
And then I think the next move,
which is gonna be incredibly
exciting, is how we start
to bring in more clinical services.
So preoperative
questionnaires for example.
- Yeah
- We don't need someone to be doing that.
We don't need someone
to be reviewing that.
You've got your set scripts,
depending on the answers,
you'll go into a green box of
"Happy day, you're good
to go for your surgery."
or "Okay, you need a review."
But again, it's taking the
pressure away from our clinical
staff, but also from our
administrative staff.
And I think every time we start to scope,
we see more opportunity
and it's, it's so exciting.
I don't think I ever thought
working in an organization
like the NHS, you'd, I mean
get the opportunity to do this.
I flew over from London
yesterday to do this.
This is, you know, amazing.
So yeah, I think the sky
really is the limit for us.
- Yeah, and I think that's so exciting.
Especially, it's the mindset,
I think in this particular
instance that made it
so successful, of just really willing
to give something a go.
- Yeah
- Leverage what had been
built successfully in other
places and kind of keep
scaling it and rolling it out.
I mean, it sounds a really
ambitious kind of vision for
what you wanna create across
your geographical area.
But I guess Andy, just
closing off with you,
like what's in your sort
of ambitious future?
- Yeah so one of the things
that using Lex to do this
encourages or invites
your customer to do is
perhaps sacrifice a little
bit of the customer experience
for a lot of the capacity release.
But with Nova Sonic arriving
and a range of models
that are gonna do voice to voice,
we can actually redress that balance.
So we make it a big investment
right now about saying
"How do we take everything we've learned
and put it in that purely
generative environment?"
So we've got rich conversations,
high customer experience,
empathy, intimacy perhaps
where it's appropriate,
to drive... greater
demand, if you like, for,
for the voice channel at
very, very little cost.
The second thing is, and picking
up a point Nicola made is
everything that your
customer wants from you
as an organization,
your staff will want from
you in some other way,
some transactional need or requirement.
And there's no reason
why you can't automate
business support using the same tools
that you use for customer support.
And I think that becomes
quite an interesting
two-dimensional approach
to using Amazon Connect.
Then the third one, I
think this is where it gets
really exciting is,
and you've heard lots of
announcements already about sort
of Agentic development is,
why do I need my citizen
or customer to phone me up?
Why can't I just get them to say,
"My agent's gonna deal with that."
And we'll create an interface that allows
their personal agent to
achieve all the things
with us as the council or
the hospital that we need
without [microphone muffles]
having to lift a finger or a microphone!
And I think that, you know
what, what becomes quite
exciting about that is we
can really empower people
on their behalf to get the
best things proactively
rather than waiting
for them to contact us.
So I think watch this space,
there's a lot coming there.
- Fantastic. Great. Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you all.